thank you so so as well as the
University of San Francisco I'm also the
co-founder of a self-funded lab cord
fast AI fast at AI actually is very
related to this quote from this obscure
person guy called Dennis Allison and
1972 created something called the
people's computer company where he said
computers are mostly used against people
instead of for people used to control
people instead of to free them time to
change all that
it was interesting to me reading this
quote because we saw something similar
similar happening with with AI which is
that AI is this super powerful set of
technologies that we saw were in the
hands of a kind of an elite few that
that elite few was pretty homogeneous
and we're not necessarily people who
deeply understood what the most pressing
societal problems in the world really
are or had the you know data to fix them
or understood the operational
constraints necessary to do something
about them and so when we started
looking into the question of like well
what would it take to make AI more
accessible so it's not in the pay in the
hands of this elite few we've we found
that the answer was quite difficult
actually so for example my my co-founder
Rachel Thomas asked one of the top
researchers in in 2013 I think it was at
a meet-up how do you actually initialize
your your models in a way that they
trained from a good starting point and
he said his response was well that's
part of a bag of tricks that nobody
publishes so it's like you couldn't even
start training because you didn't even
know how to start with your weights so
we kind of set out to change that we
started this self-funded lab cord fast
AI where we basically tried to figure
out can we get
deep learning specifically into the
hands of domain experts by which I mean
like radiologists or journalists or
lawyers or whatever so so first today I
does a number of things to try and do
this this mission of making deep
learning accessible the main thing I'm
going to focus on today is that we write
software the software we write is
basically to try and make it so that
it's it's easier to get really good
results with deep learning
we also teach which is a lot about
basically teaching how do you get really
good results with deep learning and a
lot of time part of the answer is use
the software we've written some of the
time it's not we do a lot of you know
traditional or semi traditional academic
research any time we come across
something where we think oh this is like
something that deep learning can or
should be able to do really well but
currently it doesn't do well or it's
expensive or it requires the math PhD or
whatever we do the research to figure
out how to make it easier and cheaper
and not not much data and then there's
kind of no point making something
accessible if if each person who comes
into your field is now an island you
know with with no community to reach out
to and share their work and get support
from and so forth so we also have
developed the world's largest deep
learning community which is just this
super friendly engaging and also a
highly competent online place before I
tell you about our software I'll give
you a quick sense of some of the stuff
that kind of goes into it around the
research and training that we do our
online course so you know we're we don't
have any revenues or profits or anything
like I said we're a self-funded lab so
everything we do is free and open source
and there's no ads or anything like that
so we have this course online practical
tech learning for coders which I don't
know for sure but I think it might be
the most popular tech learning course in
the world
there are 14 lessons about 28 hours of
material each lessons you expect her to
do about 10 hours of work so you know
your energy up doing well over 100 hours
of pretty intense work currently it
assumes that you've had at least a year
of solid coding experience which is a
prerequisite we would love to get rid of
one of the interesting things was were
after a course a couple of years ago I
put up a post on our community forums
saying after the first class saying like
hey did anybody build anything cool
after today's class and this was a while
ago there's now more than well more than
a thousand people who answered that by
saying yes which was super cool and so
people who as I said come into this with
a year of coding experience but no other
prerequisites so from all around the
world so no math prerequisites other
than high school math so one person said
oh I'm from Trinidad and Tobago and we
have certain kinds of Islanders and I
built a classifier to figure out what
kind of Island or a picture is of
somebody else did Sookie knees versus
cucumbers somebody else picked aerial
photos of the earth and built something
that with 85% accuracy you could figure
out what city a picture was of somebody
else classified types of Panamanian bus
the interesting thing about these is
better cloth they're generally with
here's one 300 pictures across 50 types
so like it was quite it's quite common
to have like less than 10 miniatures per
class a lot of people getting good
results with less than 50 images overall
so like definitely kind of showing you
don't need this is after one lesson so
you don't need a PhD and a data center
and a million images and so forth so
we're kind of trying to show that the
the the baseline required to get good
results in this technology it may be not
as high as people assume as an example
of figuring out different types of
addition of buildings in Tanzania this
kind of stuff super important for like
earthquake resilience and other disaster
resilience there are people working on
this field very actively to help get
teams to the places that really need the
help after a natural disaster now the
student got got straightaway a
state-of-the-art Resort better than any
academic paper for Devin Geary
classification one of the interesting
things that happens when you bring
people in from all around the world
who you know they often tackle problems
that just haven't been tackled before
whether it be you know Trinidad and
Tobago person recognition or Devon Gary
character recognition often it turns out
that to kind of create the best ever
result it doesn't actually require that
much because there just hasn't been that
much resources thrown at it before so
that's been cool what are the
interesting things is to see how people
kind of take the tools and adjust them
to work in their domain so somebody was
looking at after getting after lesson
one was looking at an environmental
sound classification and at this after
Lesson one you only know computer vision
right so they basically talk sounds and
turn them into pictures by doing
spectrograms of them and throw it
through the models that we taught in
Lesson one and again they got that
turned out they got the state of beat
easily the state of the art result from
the academic literature for
environmental sound classification
Elena Haile is amazing she's from human
long activity international she's now
created a whole bunch of projects
showing significant advances in in
genomics again she doesn't have a
background in in AI but has a very
strong background in genomics I'm
working with a Craig Venters lab and
then there are some folks who go kind of
above and beyond so one of the things we
did in lesson 7 was we showed people how
you can take you can do generative image
models which is where you take a deep
learning network where the outputs not a
classification but it's another image
and one of the folks in the course Jason
antic thought oh I wonder if that could
add color to black more images and he
tried it out and it turns out the answer
was you
you can and he's now spent over a year
working on this and this is an example
of his model that color roses this black
and white image as you can see it does a
beautiful job and actually this
technology has just been acquired by
it's got my heritage which is like the
biggest kind of family tree thing in the
world and they now I think of the first
week something like a million images
term customers got colorized so this is
something that kind of started as a
first AI student project this guy was
working at an insurance company and
turned into this passion project and is
now a commercial thing that you can that
you can go and use one of the nice
things has been to see how groups of
domain experts kind of get together and
and build cool stuff so a lot of
radiologists have gone through the
course and this is kind of really strong
alumni network of fast AI radiology kind
of practitioners so Alexander is one of
those he's now published a paper he's
won a capital competition I don't know
how these people who are working doctors
hours or every to this but there are
people who it's really cool
there there are now you know young
doctors and residents who are also
world-class D cloning practitioners and
that's been great to see oh this is a
cool example so one of our alumni
Christine Payne who seems everything she
does in the world she does incredibly
well she actually went to open AI
shortly after finishing her first AI
course and working super hard in lots of
other areas she built a neural network
music generator which was such a big
thing that the BBC Philharmonic
Orchestra commissioned to actually play
some of the music that this thing built
so she's now at open AI which is a
pretty cool research lab focusing on
deep learning and one of the interesting
things about Christine is that before
that she was a pianist so like this is a
good example of
a domain expert and giving them at all
and seeing what they what they kind of
build with it not just a pnsu stone a
thousand different things but that was
one of them as well as a course as I
mentioned we do research one of the
things I noticed early on in this
research was that people in the deep
learning community didn't seem to talk
to each other as much as they chords so
for example there was the NLP people and
there was a computer vision people and
when he built software and create
courses you kind of have to be
cross-disciplinary within the groups and
I noticed all the cool stuff in computer
vision wasn't being used in natural
language processing which I thought was
weird so I started asking um yeah so
that's yeah that's normal so I you know
I asked my friends in NLP how come
you're not using the computer vision
stuff and the answer was always that's
be a waste of time and it'll pay special
its unique you know but I did it anyway
and literally within like four hours of
trying a basic computer vision transfer
learning techniques I had broken the
state of the art for one of the most
important classification datasets in NLP
the IMDB data set so that got turned
into a course sebastian ruder who was
then doing his PhD saw that and said
that's amazing you should turn it into a
paper so Sebastian and I wrote a paper
together and that became um fit which
became pretty much the first really
strong example of of general transfer
learning and NLP Alec had fitted open Lu
I then took that and turned it into GPT
which became GPT too and Google took
that and they turned that into Bert and
now we've got this flowering of transfer
learning in NLP so often it just
requires this you know small little
observation not a whole lot of time not
a whole lot of effort to say okay maybe
these approaches would work well and
yeah so Sebastian's now at deep mind and
a lot of people now talking a lot about
the power of
find treating and transfer learning and
natural language processing one of the
challenges in in the field of deep
learning has been all the kind of hyper
hyper parameters or the settings you
have to tune to get something to train
properly so one of the things we've
tried a lot with our research is to
figure out how to make it so you don't
have to sew like we did something pretty
obvious which was to look at a whole
bunch of hyper parameters and then we
worked with a group called fellowship AI
who are basically a bunch of mainly PhD
graduates from non math and machine
learning fields so kind of economics and
political science and whatever who were
interested in getting into AI and they
helped run these experiments where
across lots of different kinds of
datasets and lots of different kinds of
hyper parameters we basically found a
set of hyper parameters so you know
yellow means it's kind of the midpoint
set of curated hyper parameters found a
set of hyper parameters where basically
there was no data set and no set of
other hyper parameters that was very
significantly better so they you can see
how this goes into the software that
kind of becomes then the defaults in the
software and then when we find places
where it's like okay this hyper
parameter does matter and it depends on
this feature of the data set or this
features the loss function we can put
those rules as just you know simple
heuristics into the software so we kind
of try to replace like Google has this
auto ml thing where they run thousands
of models and it costs a fortune of you
know to figure out what the best optimal
set of high parameters are and we kind
of try to say okay we don't want people
to have to pay Google thousands of
dollars to run every possibility let's
just give you a set that's going to work
first time so this is kind of our
approach to you know one of our
approaches to making things more
accessible one of the things we really
struggle with is people using lots of
money and lots of computers to do cool
things is super popular in the
mainstream
so and and companies like Google and
open a I want to tell this story about
how they have more resources and
everybody else and they they use those
resources to get great results and the
problem for for us is we keep meeting
people who I say hey if you ever thought
about applying deep learning to your
problem or seeing if deep learning might
be useful in your field I keep hearing
the answer I'm not going to try because
I don't have Google's computers I don't
have their amount of data I you know I
can't usefully contribute to this field
so we hear that all the time so from
time to time we try to make our own
little stamp to say you know even a
little to person self funded research
lab you know with a bunch of new
students can do you know this kind of
work so the the main one we did
particularly was dawn bench which was
actually a competition run out of
Stanford very cool competition where
they said okay rather than seeing who
can be the most accurate on imagenet
which is a very popular computer vision
data set who can train at the fastest to
you know a approximately
state-of-the-art level so kind of the
first to dive in was Intel and they
published a result on the leaderboard
using a thousand computers networked
together and they got I don't know what
it was like nine hours or something and
then Google had a big team from Google
brain working on it and they published
something that was like I can't remember
maybe it's like four hours using a whole
pot of TP use working in parallel and
then one of my students came to me and
told me about this there's the one bench
thing and said you know maybe we could
try to give it a go and see if we can
not come last which is always a good
goal so we thought we'd see if we could
not come last and we won and we won
using one computer and the key thing we
we did was just the stupid stuff that
nobody else had bothered a try most
but most importantly rather than
training on the large image net images
let's make them small and train on the
small ones
all right so 64 by 64 image compared to
a 300 by 300 image you're going to do it
10 times faster even if you only have
one computer but it's a picture of the
same thing it looks the same it's just a
bit pixelated and it's that kind of
common-sense thing where you're like
okay if a human can see that a 64 by 64
image and a 300 by 300 image look the
same the computers you know take
learning algorithm it's going to see
they look the same too so we trained 95%
of the epochs on these small images and
then at the end we gradually scaled the
month and the cool thing is that not
only is it way faster because you're
just doing less compute you also get a
very nice natural data augmentation
which is you're actually giving the
computer different resolution images
during training so it actually tends to
overfit less so you can do less epochs
and then we did other things like we
kind of try to find the research papers
that don't get noticed because they
don't come out of fancy universities
like Stanford so for example there's a
guy called Leslie Smith at the Naval
Research Lab which he's basically the
only guy working there on deep learning
stuff nobody's heard of that lab really
at least fatigue learning but it turns
out that he's he published some amazing
insights one of which he discovered that
there were certain sets of parameters in
certain situations where we could use a
10 times higher learning rate than
previously known approaches and train
things 10 times faster and he called
this thing super convergence academia
being what it is he got rejected from
every conference it never got published
but thanks to the modern world
there's a preprint on archive and we
could read it and it was clear that like
something weirds going on so so yeah
Leslie and I in first AI have kind of
collaborated informally and figured out
with the help of lots of other people
around the community how to train neural
nets super super fast
and one of the nice things is
is a great link to the course which is
that we tend to say like hey here's this
paper we found by this guy quick Leslie
Smith here's why it's interesting
and then suddenly we've got tens of
thousands of people who will who are
also enthused and so it tends to kind of
percolate up so there's this nice yeah
kind of mesh of things going on so
that's kind of how that's the feed in to
the software and I'd say honestly that
you know the focus for us is very much
moving from from education to software
development because when we started
there was like okay let's teach what's
already there and then once we felt we
were doing the best we can of that then
it's like okay well let's try and make
it so there are better things to teach
and so ideally it would be nice to get
to a point where deep learning was as
easy to use as the internet is on an
iPhone you know we're a long way away
from that yet but the only way to get
there is not by improving the training
but by improving the software people are
using so you know we have many steps to
get there but as Dennis said in the
introduction we're kind of at step two
of the software which is we've just
spent the last 18 months trying to
create the very best library for deep
learning that we can one of the I think
perhaps the most interesting insight
about this development process for me is
I have far more experience as a software
engineer and coda then as a deep
learning person you have been coding for
many decades and I love refactoring I
think refactorings super cool there are
very few people with really deep
software engineering backgrounds in the
deep learning world and so re things
like refactoring don't happen very much
faster I - is what happens when you
bring refactoring to deep learning and
it's actually quite amazing what what
happens
so the first thing I point out is what
we see here which is that you end up
with with a layered decoupled API so
people often ask us is faster I designed
like for beginners and end-users to be
like a quick out-of-the-box thing or is
it designed for researchers or or what
and that the nice thing is with a
layered API the answer is yes it's it's
all of those things which like to a
software engineer does not sound weird
back to a machine learning person that's
that's mind blowing so we have this
applications layer where these four
applications are basically things where
deep learning is pretty mature pretty
effective being used in industry and
commercially right now we've done enough
research to figure out kind of had a
package in it away it's going to it's
going to work for you with no more than
a couple of hours of training so you
know those that's the application layer
the mid layer is what all the
applications are built on which I'll
describe shortly but they're the things
which kind of researchers and people
building new applications would build on
and then the mid layer is built on this
foundation layer which has some things
that are not at all new but they're new
to this world so to give you an example
object-oriented tensors so a tensor is
kind of the basic building block of deep
learning it's it's just a it's just a an
N dimensional array not a jagged array
so that's the thing that kind of makes
it a tensor for computer scientists so
tensor for physicists is a bit different
in tensor flow and pi torch and you know
the libraries people use day to day the
types of cancer
float tensor byte tensor that's kind of
what we mean by type right so when you
have a tensor there's not much you can
do with it you can't display it or pass
it to you know prettier or flip it or
translate it or
whatever and the rest of the world
software engineers use types to describe
the semantics of what their thing is no
tensor always has semantics you know a
tensor represents a three-channel
normalized mini batch of images in
channel first access order for example
so create a type system that can
understand those kind of concepts so
that's what we did right as it's it's
not remotely innovative but it hasn't
been done in this field before so we now
have a library where you can dot show a
tensor and it works or you can not
predict on it and it was so that's kind
of some of the foundational stuff so the
applications well so this faster your
library as Dennis mentioned there's a
book coming out about it which we just
have to finish writing and there's a
paper which just came out about it as
well yeah we have enough pressure in the
applications layer there's kind of some
stuff that's across all the applications
like transfer learning for example is
fundamental to fast AI transfer learning
is a thing where you don't have to start
with a neural net that can't do anything
at all you start with somebody else's
neural net that does something a bit
like what you want and then you
fine-tune it that's what transfer
learning is it turns out that how you
transfer learn matters a lot
very few academics have spent any time
focusing on this question it's not a
popular research question but it's like
just about the most popular most
important practical question so we spent
a lot of time figuring out how to do
this well and it's all built into the
first day a library so for every
application you can literally call a
fine-tuned method and it does all the
transfer learning best practices we also
try to make it easy to figure out what's
going on and specifically if something's
not going well why isn't it going well
so we provide these kind of graphs that
show what's happening each line is a
different layer of the model and of the
x-axis is different mini-batches being
passed through and we look at the means
and standard deviations of the layers in
various different ways one of the really
interesting ones is this thing which we
call the colorful dimension which these
four pictures are four layers of a
neural network that's training the again
the x axis is batch is mini-batches so
it's kind of time and if you like and
each set of pixels represents a log
normalized histogram of all of the
activations in that layer so when you
see kind of all the color down here it
indicates that nearly all of the
activations are close to zero and when
you see it spread out like this it means
that there's activations throughout the
neural net and generally speaking this
is bad because it means that you've got
like a very sparse set of activations so
it's not doing much computation you've
got tens of millions of activations but
most of them aren't doing anything at
all and so this is fascinating thing
when you create this picture you
discover that for many neuron it's when
you start training the the kind of
spread of activations goes up nicely and
then it crashes and then goes up but it
kinda goes up exponentially and crashes
and because that text in your question
so we had never seen this picture drawn
before we before we created this and
it's a sudden like a-ha moment where
you're like this has got to be bad right
because every time it comes up and
crashes it's got a whole lot of work to
do to make these activations anything
other than zero and you can see that by
the time you get to the fourth layer
it's it's very very clear so one of our
students actually Stephan all spent a
lot of time during a course on like
drawing up different ways that we could
represent this and helped us create
these beautiful pictures but it actually
turns out after all that one line is
really what you want and that line is at
each mini-batch what percentage of the
activations for a laya r0 and so for
this training in layer four you can see
that basically you get to nearly all of
them a zero and so you would never know
this without these pictures you would
just be like oh my models 90% accurate
it's a bit disappointing but so be it
but actually if you look inside you
realize my models not working well at
all so in this case we realized that
there was a key issue that the the main
activation function called the rectified
linear unit actually doesn't have a mean
of zero value basically removes all
negatives and replaces them with zeros
which by definition has a positive mean
so we just subtracted 0.4 from riolu and
reran the exact same model and this is
the pictures we got and you can see it
the entire that problem is totally gone
away and the percent of zeros is great
and we ended up with a more accurate
model which trained more quickly so
there's kind of these you know these
defaults and these insights and kind of
this focus where we just try to make
things work well in practice so we end
up with this nice situation where for
example there's a computer vision
library where we just say import the
vision library and then there's kind of
one two three one two three four lines
of code and it gives you so in this case
we're getting a nine percent error rate
after 35 seconds for recognizing which
one of 37 pet breeds there's an image
that's basically the same one two three
four lines of code will also fit this
data set which will mark every pixel in
an image with what kind of object that
pixel represents and you can see where
the object-oriented stuff comes in I can
say show batch and because fast AI knows
that the input type is an image in the
output type is a mask it knows that the
correct way to display it is to provide
a color coded mask with an alpha
overlaid on top of the image
and it's the same thing with the model
you could say show results and it'll
show you the results with the same way
so without the kind of the typed
foundation you would you don't need a
different function for every combination
it will get pretty unwieldy so text
classification the same lines of code to
a text classification and also again
show batch is now going to show you your
your texts tabular analysis the same
basic lines of code will analyze tables
of data collaborative filtering the same
basic lines of code will do a
collaborative filtering and so this
stuff turns out to work super well so
people sometimes jump now for him and so
this person said oh I just started and I
just comparing it to my chance of flow
to models and I can't understand why
everything's so much better I'm trying
to make it as less good as I can and it
still much better so like what he kind
of build in the best practices into the
library so then somebody replied to that
400 some company he said yep we were
using transfer flow before spent months
tweaking first ai2 days we were getting
better results it's important to support
kind of incrementally moving across so
fast AI lives on top of pi torch it
absolutely wouldn't be possible without
pi torch which is just a fantastic piece
of software and so one of the things we
do is you know you can take the official
pi torch repository example code delete
30 the 30 lines in the training loop and
replace it with these three lines and
you get all of the benefits of fasting i
training with you know existing with
existing code you don't get all the
benefits of the libraries or things like
show batch won't work because pi torch
native doesn't have the same concept of
like type sensors and things but gets
you some of the way there so as i
mentioned and this is the thing I'm most
interested in excited about I think for
first di2 is this mid layer API because
this is something that it's not
and at all uncommon in software
engineering but it hasn't existed before
in the deep learning world and it's a
it's basically a refactoring of the
pieces that make up those applications
so silver who's the person who I wrote
this Wiz created this bit about one of
the pieces of this mid layer which is
the training loop this is what a
training loop looks like in PI torch
you basically loop through epochs you
look through MIDI batches you get your
predictions you call your loss function
and you do the backward pass to get the
gradients and you step your optimizer so
you basically do these things right now
the problem is that there's lots of
tweaks you keep track of metrics you
have hyper parameter schedulers there's
all kinds of regularization techniques
you might want to handle 1/2 precision
floating point training you might want
to do complex training like generative
adversarial networks so either you do
what everybody else does which is to
write a new training loop from scratch
every time or you try and do what I try
to do in fast AI 0.7 which is to create
one training loop that has everything
and that led to my early insanity or you
do what we do now which is to add what
we call two-way callbacks at every point
during training a two-way callback is
something where a callback can read
everything every bit of state every bit
of data every gradient every hyper
parameter and can write them all back
and can change the control flow so you
can you know inject functionality that
has access to the world and can change
the world
so basically you start with a loop that
looks like that and you end up with one
with the same steps that a whole bunch
of call backs and so callbacks end up
being these like tiny little pieces of
code that do a whole lot of stuff so for
example an early stopping callback would
define and after a park which would
check for some function of the recorded
values and it wants to stop we use
exceptions or control flow you can raise
a canceled fit exception there's also
canceled batch canceled validation and
so forth
or gradient flipping so if you want to
avoid activations which are going off to
infinity
there can be an after backward step
which actually modifies the parameters
of the model and changes their gradients
for instance so it's been amazingly
successful basically everything we've
tried to add every paper we've
implemented every experiment we've done
we've been able to do without changing
the training loop just by changing
callbacks yeah yeah so can you reason
about the callback so if you didn't
write them yes absolutely the the nice
thing is that well for one thing there's
great documentation and the the
callbacks are they're very they're very
easy to reason but reason about because
they have very consistent names you know
so before that shore after that shore
before loss or after loss and the other
thing is we we try to write our code in
a way that is just super easy to
understand what's going on so one of the
things is actually that's interesting is
all of the entire library is written
interpreter notebooks and so we've built
this new system called env dev which
allows you to kind of do true literate
programming so if you if you look at the
code in the notebooks it takes you
through every step of like what are we
doing and here's a link to the paper and
here's a picture of it and here's a
graph and so forth and then it exports
it into standard Python modules which
you can then look through in your editor
and if you prefer you can edit them in
an editor and then synchronize them back
to the notebooks so the if you want to
know what's going on in the training
loop then you know ideally you just use
the documentation but if you want to
really know what's going on
you can actually say okay here is here
is the piece that does one batch right
and we really try to lay things out so
you can see what's going on so you can
see here like no Auto code formatting
for us right like lay it out in the grid
here is the list of each callback that
happens in one batch here is a list of
each piece of code that happens in one
batch book across here is the connection
between HP to code and H callback right
so you know we try to make it so that
you can see what's going on as well and
then you can jump into the notebook and
see the experiments and the tests and
and so forth so yeah we try to make it
so that it's everybody can contribute
and do their own stuff and of course we
have this great community as well where
we help and they help each other which
works great too so for example here's a
really really important regularizer
cord mix up mix up is a fantastic data
augmentation procedure which takes two
images or whatever and basically takes a
weighted average of the two images and
then takes a weighted average of the two
sets of labels and that becomes the data
for a model it turns out that with mix
up you can use far less data and get far
better results and so here's here's the
size have mix up a GPU accelerated
version of mix up I might add in as a
first day a callback and here's the
version in the from the research paper
right so a few things to note here the
first is you know the first day I call
back is much shorter and shorter is not
just good because it's short but it's
good because each line of code that's
pretty directly to a line in the paper
of the algorithm there's not the
boilerplate more importantly the
research code only works with one data
set so far 10 it only works with one
metric it doesn't work with any other
regular Iser with any other training
tweak and so forth right with callbacks
you know you get the nice software
engineering principle of like decoupled
pieces that can work together another
example of this sort of refactoring is
optimizers there's been a lot of
developments in optimizers in the last
12 to 18 months including people kind of
combining optimizers together in
interesting ways
now the four first day I came along
these different optimizers lived in
their own worlds there wasn't really
this ability to combine them so for
example there was a really important
paper called decoupled wait okay which
developed something called atom W which
showed that the way people have been
doing probably just about the most
popular optimizer chord atom was all
wrong though there was you know a pretty
minor tweak to the equation it turned
out that made it work much better and
was like much more mathematically sound
in play torch it took a couple of years
for atom W to get implemented and this
is the basic code and they basically
rewrote all of atom plus the one tweak
first day I implemented atom W like the
day after we noticed the paper and in
our case we had to add these four lines
of code and this section in gray because
we had refactored optimizers so we
looked at lots of optimizers and just
factored out the the common pieces of
code and and ideas and so it turns out
that there's two main ideas in an
optimizer one is keep track of stuff so
the moving average gradients or the
moving average gradient squared or the
most recent gradients or whatever and
then update things in some way so for
example add the learning rates times the
gradients to the weights that's the most
basic SGD update step so we basically
provide optimizer callbacks to let you
do those two things
yourself and to mix and match the
existing ones and that's why our
students are able to write things like
this where they say oh we've taken these
things in this paper and these things
from this paper and it turns out we end
up with something that's better than any
paper so it's really cool for kind of
identifying interesting research
directions and trying things out so like
this paper on reducing Burt pre-training
time came up with a really nifty
optimizer called the lam optimizer this
is our implementation of the lam
optimizer that we had wrote the day
after the paper came out and one of the
nice things is that you can compare it
directly to the math and it's pretty
much line for line the same except the
math actually hides some things that
aren't in the paper so it actually also
makes it more explicit as to what's
going on as everybody knows one of the
hard parts about any kind of machine
learning is getting the data in order
and so I used to drive myself a bit
crazy with this because I would try to
make it easy to get your data in order
and so I so Sylvia and I had in first
day one dozens of classes for what if
your input is images and your output is
a single label classification what if
it's an import in the multi-label
classification what if it's a
black-and-white import in a single label
classification you know what if you're
doing the validation set is just fine
based on what folder it's the inverses
you want to do a random split and we
just ended up with all this code and all
this complexity and it was too hard for
us and it was too hard for our users and
so we kind of stepped back and we
thought oh let's refactor all those
classes so we realized there was
basically a small number of things that
you need to tell the the algorithm how
to do it and so basically you have to
say what are the types of my inputs what
are the types of my outputs and one of
the nice things is when you refactor it
this way you
do more interesting things like Siamese
networks where there are actually two
input images in a boolean output for
instance so you don't have to always
have one on one or unpaired image
translation like cycle gains where
there's like two inputs or no output so
and again this is where the types come
in so we have proper types so we can
define what the types are and then you
say okay how do you take for example a
list of file names and convert them into
those types and so there are certain
defaults like if the type is an image
and it's a file name by default it
assumes it would image don't open that
file name but you can override those
things in any way you like particularly
important for labeling right there's a
thousand different ways to label things
and so you couldn't you know there are
regex labelers or there are the parent
folder name could be a label ER so we
kind of extracted out all the common
labelers and also provided some building
blocks for doing your own and then okay
how do you create your validation set is
it random is that the last thousand
records is it based on the grandparent
folder name again we given some kind of
classes that do some of the standard
things and let you build your own and
then once you've got all these things
you then
callate the data into mini-batches and
there are some certain choices you make
like a batch size and stuff like that so
we end up with this thing called data
block where you say these are my types
this is the function that finds the in
this case the file names this is the
class which splits based in this case
based on the grandparent folder name
this is my labeling function which is
going to do the parent folder name and
so this will do the m-most data set
there's you know same basic idea with
very few changes will do you know here's
a regex label for doing pets here's one
for doing multi-label classification so
we've got an image and a multi category
dependent variable we've already seen
segmentation so an image input and a
mask out port
key points you know so now a tensor
point is the output object detection so
bounding box is the output and so forth
so yeah that's the bit which I'm kind of
most excited about because it means that
researchers you know can or people
trying to get more performance or
customized things for their organization
or whatever can get underneath the
surface they don't have to write stuff
from scratch but they also have a lot of
flexibility so then finally that is
built on these kind of foundation layer
we've already mentioned object oriented
tenses so you can go image dot flip and
it flips it regardless of whether it's a
pillow image or a tensor image or even
it could be a bounding box or it could
be a point cloud you know all of these
things have a concept of a flip we we
try to really take advantage of the fact
that python is a dynamic language
there's a lot of downsides to Python but
python is kind of what we're stuck with
for now that's that's where the world of
deep learning is so if we're stuck with
that we most will make the most of it so
a dynamic language like Python lets you
define decorators which add
functionality to existing classes for
example so we've created this patch
decorator which will add flip left-right
to each of these types so people who
have not really used types even though
there are type annotations in Python
people who haven't really used them that
much on the whole so we use them a lot
you wish yeah and they're mainly
designed for static analysis but
actually you know that as you can see
here the the basic mechanics are all
there that we can use them at runtime in
this way and the patch decorator itself
is like two lines of code
so yeah with that we can kind of have
show batch two different things and
actually and also this is kind of nice
like show results so for example show
results we can do things like
automatically color code things where
the classification is is wrong for
instance so one of the things we did to
make stuff like this work is we created
a new type dispatch system and again
Python is this you know wonderfully
dynamic language it's got a super great
metaclass system which is really
underutilized and so we use the metal
class system to create the new type
dispatch system which allows us to
annotate like so and end up with
something that kind of feels more like
Julia than traditional Python and this
is working great for us because it's
actually allowed us to do things like
this this dispatch system does the kinds
of things that machine learning people
need so for example we tend to have mini
batches with an independent variable
independent variable and in hi torch
these are represented as triples this
type dispatch system when it gets a
tuple by default it doesn't look for a
tuple type annotation it pulls the
triple apart and looks at each component
of that tuple that's tight and puts each
one a part of the tuple out to separate
functions based on the type of spatch
system and then pulls them back together
again so that means people can create
pipelines which we'll see in a moment
where those pipelines basically say for
example flip and if that's a mini batch
containing a point cloud dependent
variable and a color image independent
variable both of those will be flipped
automatically by the type dispatch
system so it makes a lot of the code
just much simpler much shorter and so
this this ends up in this transform
pipeline system the idea of pipelines in
machine learning data processing goes
back a long time a pipeline is just
a compact just it's just function
composition basically but one of the
things that we wanted to do with
pipelines so they're really impact lines
function composition is very important
for data processing because generally to
get from like a file name to a
normalized image batch of tenses in the
right access order
there's just steps you take in each
one's just a function applied to the
previous result the thing is that we
wanted to be able to go the other way as
well
which is to start with so you call a
prediction on a model you get back some
tensor which represents basically the
endpoint of that processing I need to go
reverse back through the pipeline to get
back you know the image in a form I can
see it or the class as a string with the
correct name so these pipelines these
transforms actually are reversible it's
not automatic there's no concept of an
inverse function in Python you just
write the inverse function each time you
want to create an invertible function
and then the pipeline will automatically
do the composition in in reverse order
great so I think five thirty at a time
work like okay great oh yes I mean
anytime also so sure I'm nearly out of
I'm really out of slides anyway but so
here's a really great example for us
especially for me right I I tried to
create a data loader with silver a
couple of years ago for fast AI v1 for
language modeling language modeling is a
really important technique in modern NLP
and it's kind of the basis of our LM fit
algorithm I described simple idea
predict the next word in in a sequence
of words and it turns out that if you
can predict the next word in a sequence
of words that that kind of model learns
a lot about not just language but about
the world so for example if the sentence
is you know some quote you know as said
by the forty-fifth
the united states president la to finish
that you need to not only know about
english but about the concept of a
president and which country it probably
was and who was the president knew the
45th president so language models are
super important and the creating a data
set which kind of has a corpus of text
and there's then the same corpus of text
offset by one is surprisingly fiddly
because you actually have to kind of
batch that up and feed it to a GPU a
batch at a time in a way that all the
batches line up with each other and it
doesn't get to cheat by kind of seeing
what the next token was and Papapa so in
first AI vision one we just had page
after page of code which we just
couldn't understand or maintain even
though we wrote it you know how it is
and then fourth version too we were able
to throw it all away and just use these
these these this pipeline approach these
transformations and also again callbacks
so our data loader is almost entirely
api compatible with the pi torch data
loader but it has i think 16 callback
points you can hook into where else the
pi torch one has you know a small
handful and so it just made this code so
much simpler easier to read easier to
write which is great
none of this is really much use unless
it's fast
there's no point giving people stuff
that's that's pretty and concise if it
isn't performant enough to be useful so
we wrote you know as optimized a
foundation for everything as we could so
some you know really easy to use
parallelization constructs in python and
then use those in for example
tokenization so tokenizing has
traditionally been this really slow
thing we can't particularly make it
faster but we can make it so that it
will automatically paralyze tokenization
and you can pick any tokenizer you want
so to do this we tend to take a lot of
advantage of the lazy generator
functionality in Python which
makes a lot of this stuff kind of
trivially easy unfortunately the the
Python has a global interpreter lock
which can get in the way but most of the
things that we're calling written in C
so that doesn't impact things as much as
you might expect we've written a new
computer vision library which actually
runs on the GPU using PI torch and it's
really interesting there's a really
small number of basic foundational piece
pieces that you need in a tensor library
to be able to do pretty much anything
you want in computer vision so we have
this affine coordinate transform which
basically takes something called a flow
field which is basically says
whereabouts should each pixel be moved
to and with a flow field you can zoom
you can warp you can rotate we use lazy
operations so that all of the cordon
operations and f-fine transforms operate
on the flow field and then there's this
really cool thing in patriach called
grid sample which takes a flow field and
an image and moves the pixels and does
the interpolation and padding and so
forth so that's been super fun to kind
of create this thing entirely in Python
where people can write new GPU
accelerated computer vision stuff
entirely in Python and see exactly
what's going on yeah so I think that's
that's everything
questions please yes so I should mention
like we almost entirely only write
Python Silva has written a little bit of
courtesy plus plus stuff for one
particular thing we needed but it's
basically all Python as it stands to get
decent performance reasonably reliably
without too much fuss you pretty much
have to use NVIDIA GPUs so so as I say
we sit on top of pi torch we desperately
hope that other GPU manufacturers will
start delivering decent libraries so
that that will change but it's happening
very slowly
yep yep okay so what prompted is to
create vision to what would prompt us to
create version three is actually a
really good question
version two is a rewrite from scratch
and it was clearly needed because until
version two we've always operated under
significant time constraints so you know
self created time constraints which is
generally like we want to have something
ready for a course so we never actually
shipped a library I would say we were
proud of I would say we thought it was
better than anybody else's library doing
similar stuff but it was nowhere near as
good as we thought it should be so we
made a conscious decision to to take 18
months off and have no deadlines and
start from scratch and build the best of
everything we could so that's why we
have a new type you know what the new
type is batch system and a new
transformation pipeline and all this
stuff and a new computer vision library
because every time we got to a point
where we thought like oh this this is
not as good as it could be whether we
had written it or somebody else we
decided to fix it so it's kind of like a
pretty key moment for us because we now
do feel like this is the best we can
create not just in the time but just the
best we can create today . and so we've
decided to also step back and like write
a book about it
let me try to write the best book we can
and to create now the best course we can
so like what would lead to version 3 is
a is a great question
my hope is that version 3 will be where
we really want to get to which is like
something that requires little or no
code version 3 maybe won't be a library
maybe it'll be a GUI application or
GUI application with a thin library
underneath or something because
hopefully we've built this foundation
feels like it's kind of should be solid
enough that we don't need to pull it
apart and start again you know this is
so many injection points or callbacks or
whatever it feels like it should be
extensible it doesn't feel particularly
tied to how deep learning is done today
but kind of fundamentally to he'll kind
of data processing pipelines and
modeling has to work sure how is
generalized how is generalized really
different to changing the bias so the
the key reason is batch norm so batch
norm will we'll move it to where it
wants to and so then the rel you will
kick in and then the output of that will
have the you know an average you don't
want so you you still end up with a
nonzero main at the end of each kind of
super layer if you like so
we saw that in practice having a non
zero mean makes it very hard to maintain
a unit variance and that's actually the
thing you really care about so and I
will say it turns out this observation
we were not the only ones to make it
this idea of centralized values has as
appeared elsewhere there's a thing
called cell you see elu which is a
centralized exponential unit and yeah
how much it matters depends a lot like
if if you can have batch norm everywhere
it's much less of an issue but
particularly for something like Aaron n
we're batch norms not really not
you know or things where you have to
have very very small batches so batch
nom doesn't really work this kind of
really good initialization matters that
it's very hard it's not really possible
to get really good initialization
without a centralized activation
function and some of our students have
actually found now I don't think any of
its published yet but there are
combinations of specific units and
centralized activation functions that'll
that's one of our students trained
thousand layer deep networks without
batch norm which is pretty cool so we
have a peer-reviewed paper in
information which you know honestly I
mean the reviewers were super helpful
but the the help was around wording
tweaks little missing citations there
was nothing surprising because of the
the wider community who's already been
pounding on this for a while so we do
all of our work entirely in the open and
every time we push something significant
we tell people about it on the forum no
no I know I'm getting there yeah so so
as a result of that there is a hardcore
group that keep up and I try to help
them keep up so for example when fast AI
to first kind of got to a point where it
could do things I
did you know it's 12 hours of video code
walkthroughs with a group of people
online with me asking me questions and
what we found is a lot of people are
really interested in AI and a lot of
people interested enough that they give
up their jobs and spend a year studying
it and a lot of those people will turn
out to be like super high achieving
kinds of people you know people a lot of
people who can do that do that because
they just sold their company or whatever
so we kind of have this really nice
hardcore community of people who are you
know absolutely trying out every new
line of code as we add it telling us
about things that don't work building
new things so there's a you know and
then they form on the community they
form these kind of no study groups so
there's an audio study group so there's
no fast AI audio yet but there is a fast
AI dot audio library built by this
community of people who know a lot more
about audio than I do
same with time series there's a nice
time series study group who you know who
have been creating state-of-the-art
results with fast AI with time-series
building time series applications it's
not you know it's it's a minority of the
community which as it should be most of
the community are just using it to do
stuff I will say this though pi torch is
by far by far the most popular library
used for research so like it at at just
within the last 12 months
Europe's it went from tensorflow being
like 75% of the publications to pi torch
being like 75% of the publications and
increasingly
you know as fast I to mature was more
and more of those researchers are
looking to do stuff with the first AI as
well and then naturally have a tendency
to push deep into the code because they
need to try things that haven't been
tried before
how many people
it could be hundreds but but I also know
there's a lot more than I know about
like sometimes things pop up so like a
couple of weeks ago this paper appeared
from de Shore research Saudi sure David
Shores was one of the top you know
billionaire hedge fund guys who founded
a research group a few years ago cool
okay so so he's now spending his time
doing biotech research and I was
delighted to find this paper up here
where they're using fast AI to to create
a state-of-the-art protein analysis
system and I only found out about it
because one of those people came back to
take our most recent course and
introduce themselves in the forum and
said oh by the way you should check out
on your paper you know so I know there's
a bigger group another example I know
like somebody from not somebody the VP
of AI and ml Glasgow SmithKline
contacted me last week and said hey
everybody who comes to GSK it takes your
course your library is integrated into
our HPC clusters that's like I had no
idea so it's very hard to judge
[Applause]